in 1944 just before the d-day invasion
general patton addressed his troops i'm
going to clean this up a little bit
because this is a family show general
patton said quote
we're not going to just shoot the sons
of lady dogs we're going to rip out
their living gd guts and use them to
grease the treads of our tanks we're
going to murder those lousy hun blank
suckers by the bushel effing basket war
is a bloody killing business you've got
to spill their blood or they will spill
yours rip them up the belly shoot them
in the guts when shells are hitting all
around you and you wipe the dirt off
your face and realize that instead of
dirt it's the blood and guts of what was
once your best friend beside you you'll
know what to do
that's how the military used to talk
yesterday the marine corps and the air
force tweeted out pictures of rainbows
and wished everyone a happy pride month
the marines declared their commitment to
quote fostering an environment free from
discrimination and treating quote all
equally with dignity and respect
now nice as all that sounds
that is not the job of the u.s military
the us military is not an hr department
at some millennial tech startup the job
of the military is to kill our enemies
at least it was
for years the military held out as one
of the last institutions to resist
leftist takeover
those days appear to be finished
today the radical leftists who run our
armed forces whine about white rage
they give patriotic servicemen the boot
for not taking the fouchy auchi they
cram the rhetoric of diversity equity
and inclusion down the throats of the
brave men and women who volunteer to
serve and kill the bad guys
the radicals who have taken control of
our military don't really care so much
about winning wars abroad they're much
more interested in winning the
ideological war at home and in that war
as far as the radicals are concerned the
enemy
is us for the next
28 29 days things are going to get
super
duper
gay
really really gay okay and you saw it in
the military that was bad enough kind of
ironic too that the military is
promoting diversity that great speech i
read from george patton up there at the
top he has a whole section of that
speech where he says i don't want any of
this individualism crap okay you're in
the military you just you do what
everyone else is doing and you shoot and
you kill the enemy and you follow orders
diversity has no place in the military
when when servicemen
suit up and they're getting ready for
battle do they put on
diverses do they do they button up all
of their diverses and then go out there
to fight no they put on their uniforms
because diversity is not what you want
in the military you want absolute
uniformity
i'm not saying uniformity of race or
uniform but you want
uniformity at a deep level you want
everyone to be doing
the same
thing and you don't want people
expressing their weird sexual desires or
appetites that has no place in the
military
if you have something eccentric or
unusual or distracting from the mission
repress it keep it to yourself it's not
about you it's about the country and
protecting the country and killing the
enemies that's what the military used to
be about but not even the military is
immune these days from all this wokeness
certainly corporate america is not
immune
we saw this yesterday with starbucks
starbucks announced
when we are recognized and accepted for
who we are our communities are stronger
for it during pride month we join our
lgbtqia
two
plus partners there's a two what does
the two stand for i don't know
partners employees in supporting trans
equality
who advocate for the acceptance and
understanding of transgender people so
starbuck's coming out as extremely gay
we knew starbucks was very very gay ever
since they premiered these sous-vide egg
bites that i think was the the proof
positive and they're very delicious egg
bites so there you have it
starbucks and every other corporation in
america just about is going to be
embracing the rainbow you're seeing this
at the level of the government joe biden
yesterday tweeted out quote
during pride month
we honor the resilience of lgbtqi
plus people so no a no two very
discriminatory from biden
these people who are fighting to live
authentically and freely we reaffirm
that lgbtqi
plus rights are human rights
and we recommit to delivering
protections safe safety and equality
so everyone can realize the full promise
of america
it's an important point here because
you're going to hear this phrase a lot
lgbtq
writes
there is no such thing as lgbtq rights
it's a phrase that people will use
just like they invent all sorts of
rights these days but there is no right
to that
i'm not saying that people who have some
sexual confusion or an unusual sexual
identity don't have any rights they have
certain rights but there is no such
thing as lgbtqi
rights just because you say something is
a right doesn't mean that it is
rights are actually grounded in reality
if rights are to have any meaning at all
let's just take the t because it's the
clearest example
a man does not have a right to pretend
that he's a woman
that's actually wrong of him to do he
he if
if the source of our rights is just our
making a claim for them then there's no
end to that but of course there are no
such rights the
biden administration the left is trying
to invent civil rights to that but it
doesn't exist it's not it's not right at
all and this is not just about inclusion
and being very nice and being very
accepting this is very very aggressive
we we just saw yesterday
and this wouldn't be the first time
we've seen this the united states
government flying a pride flag
at the vatican
at the holy see
it says quote
today is the start of pride month the
united states respects and promotes the
equality and human dignity of all people
including the
lgbtqia plus community
pride month hashtag all inclusive
hashtag pride2022.
the libs are going to play this off and
say look this is just a positive
affirmation of our view of sexuality and
pride but it's not positive because they
don't do this in muslim countries they
don't do this in saudi arabia they don't
do this in places where they
where they think it's going to result in
a a bombing or a suicide attack
this is not about affirming lgbt this is
about attacking christianity this is
about attacking the traditions in the
west if it weren't they'd be flying
these flags in saudi arabia and
throughout the muslim world but they're
not because it's not it's not about the
rainbow it's not about lgbt it's about
saying
fu
to
tradition to our traditional
understanding of how to behave
i'm glad you like that clip now
ring
ding subscribe listen guys this is pride
month okay i don't know what that has to
do with anything but come on all right
this is when we've got to get serious
you got to be inclusive you've got to be
diverse you've got to open your mind to
lots of new opinions and notifications
ring ding subscribe do what you got to
do apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe there as well to the
michael knowles show we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]